c'est une start up à la pointe de la
biotechnologie sky thérapeutique se
développent un traitement pour la
myopathie de duchenne une dégénération
des muscles chez l'homme une entreprise
créée en 2015 est incubé à la faculté de
médecine de l'université versailles
saint quentin et les recherches
commencent à aboutir l'avancée majeure
c'est d'avoir mis au point une molécule
donc un médicament potentiellement pour
traiter cette maladie qui est difficile
à traiter parce qu'elles touchent tout
le corps il faut il faut pouvoir
atteindre tout le corps donc ça c'est
particulièrement complexe à l'origine de
cette start-up plusieurs associations de
parents d'enfants atteints de la
myopathie de duchenne à leurs côtés le
docteur luis garcia directeur de
recherche au cnrs il travaille depuis
une vingtaine d'années sur ce sujet j'ai
commencé par faire de la thérapie
génique il ya une quinzaine d'années
mathen d'année et puis en parallèle de
cette thérapie génique on a travaillé
avec des chimistes au fil du temps les
en comparant l'efficacité s'est rendu
compte que la solution chimique
n'étaient pas aussi mauvaises qu'on
qu'on pouvait l'anticiper et qu'elle
même elle est très prometteuse et nous
avons développé cet axe jusqu'à
aujourd'hui est en mesure de proposer un
essai clinique dans les mois qui
viennent les essais devraient commencer
à l'automne 2022 l'aboutissement d'un
long travail de recherche devenu concret
avec la création de sky therapeutics un
exemple dans la filière de la
biotechnologie sur le territoire de
paris saclay la filière santé à paris
saclay c'est à peu près 40% des start up
qui naissent et qui s'y développe donc
voila l illustre bien aussi cette
excellence sur l'industrie santé
biotechnologies et puis elle est incubé
hébergés ici au sein de l'ufr simone
veil qui a la faculté de médecine de
l'hiver est ce qu est donc de
l'université paris saclay donc voilà
c'est une très belle illustration de du
parcours d'une entreprise qui n'est ici
qui se développe ici dans un no 47 lieu
d'innovation et plusieurs lieux
d'innovation du pôle paris saclay seront
à découvrir le 12 et 13 mai prochain
durant l'événement spring paris saclay